الاحتجاجات ملات شوارع العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس اعتراضا على مشروع قانون لتعديل
نظام التقاعد اذ يواصل العمال في العديد
من القطاعات الخدميه الاحتجاجات ضد خطه
الحكومه بشان سن التقاعد حيث ستتعطل شبكه
السكك الحديديه والحركه الجويه مره اخرى
في البلاد لكن مشاهدينا ورغم الاحتجاجات
يبدو ان خطه حكومه الرئيس الفرنسي
لاقرار مشروع قانون لتعديل نظام التقاعد
المثير للجدل في طريقها للاقرار اولى هذه
الخطوات جاءت بتمرير مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي
ماده رئيسيه في مشروع القانون تنص على رفع
سن التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عاما وذلك رغم
معركه اجرائيه حاده مع اليسار كما صوت 201
من اعضاء الاعضاء اعضاء المجلس لصالح رفع
سن التقاعد مقابل 115 عضوا صوت ضده